bon philippe est c'est fait c'est fait
les deux philippines risque de patrice
de voix pour une de ces jeunes filles et
bien comment ça pas la dernière
sandra la wii en plus nous allons passer
c'est à dire de continuer à voter parmi
l'italie c'est de relever le niveau du
jury s'il vous plaît mon prénom vous
êtes de véritables spécialistes du
service public ils n'en peuvent plus et
permet leur job
alors vous avez à numéroter les feux de
36 15 godet faire trop à ça que la
première fois j'entends 66k
après ce jeu de séduction et ça va du
jury tous dans la délicatesse des
lancements de remonter plus loin dans
les étoiles avec beaucoup de remue
méninges et klaus avait souffert alors
certes un signal évident le plus douteux
dégringole dans le mois et le premier
des grandes lois aujourd'hui c'est moi
le premier c'est quand même le scorpion